[MUSIC PLAYING]
IKAI LAN: Hey everybody.
Welcome to another edition of
YouTube Developers Live.
My name is Ikai Lan.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And this
is Ibrahim Ulukaya.
IKAI LAN: And today what we're
going to be talking about is
using IDEs with the YouTube
API samples.
Now, after I'm done with that,
Ibrahim's going to talk a
little bit about the YouTube
samples and the code--
the code and the samples
themselves.
But for the first part of this,
I was really excited to
do the show because a lot of
what we're going to talk about
is also going to be applicable
to many of the APIs that we
have available.
For instance, if you want to
work with Google Drive API,
you could use many of the same
steps to import into your IDE.
And if it isn't clear, we're
talking about Java.
So the two IDEs that I'll be
using today are going to be
Eclipse and IntelliJ.
So with that, are you
ready to being?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
Sure, let's go.
IKAI LAN: So I'm going to take
my trusty laptop here and put
it into my lap.
And this is running OS X, but
these commands should more or
less be the exact same across
platform, because I think that
Eclipse and IntelliJ have done
a really good job of more or
less making the experience the
same across the different
development platforms.
It's just that on some platforms
if I were to do
anything on the command line,
I might have slightly
different commands or I would
have to do things a little bit
differently.
So what we're looking
at right now is the
YouTube API samples page.
This is a Google Code project
that contains all of our
sample projects.
So it includes our sample code
that show you how to do basic
things such as uploading a
video, posting a bulletin,
doing a search--
basically, a lot of things
you want to do.
So how do you get
to this page?
Well, you go to code.google.com/
p/youtube-api-samples, or you
can just search for YouTube
API samples and what will happen
is this will be one of
the top results.
Now my samples--
or my search results might be
ordered differently from
yours, but it'll be on the
first page for sure.
So now that we're on this page,
we want to download the
samples here from download
samples.
And you'll see that we have a
.zip file here that we can
click and start downloading
samples.
I've already done this, and I've
already unzipped it to
save us some time.
Now let's start talking
about--
oops, let's start talking
about Eclipse.
Eclipse is one of the most
popular Java IDEs.
I mean, it's free.
You've got lots of different
options.
There are many, many plug-ins.
What I'm running here is I'm
running a newer version of
Eclipse, so let's take a look
at what version I'm running.
I'm running Eclipse Kepler,
and this is either
Eclipse 4.2 or 4.3.
What's important is that--
excuse me--
we're using something nowadays
to bundle all of our samples
called Maven.
If you've never used Maven
before, Maven is a Java build
and distribution system that
effectively you configure an
XML file-- and I'll show
you a little bit of
what this looks like--
of all your dependencies.
And when you're building, Maven
will check to see if
those dependencies exist on
your system and in your
library, in your code.
If they do not, it's going
to go to the internet.
It's going to download these
sources, and it's going update
your build path.
So you include the appropriate
.jar files and dependencies
when you're compiling
your code.
And this is really a huge deal,
I think, because prior
to this we were using Ant, and
we used to tell people, well,
go find this .jar file, go
find this .jar file, and
compile this, and that's kind
of crazy, don't you think?
It's like you've got to go
around, and you've got to play
this Where's Waldo game to
find your dependencies.
And Maven makes this
really easy.
A second thing is that with
Maven there's a very defined
kind of structure for what your
projects more or less
look like, and this makes it
really easy for IDEs to import
your project.
So I'm going to show you
what this means.
I've already imported a few
projects here, but that's
because this is for Ibrahim
afterwards to walk us
through some code.
So what I'm going to do right
now is I'm going to go ahead,
and I'm going to import
the YouTube
command line search sample.
And how do we do this?
Well, again, I'm running
Eclipse Kepler.
Most versions of Eclipse past
4.2 for Java, these will
include the m2eclipse plug-in.
If you're using an older
version of Eclipse--
I'm going to go back to
Chrome real quick--
you'll need to install
m2eclipse.
You need to install this
plug-in if you don't
already have it.
And the way you do this is the
same as the way you would
install most Java plug-ins where
you copy the URL, you go
to Eclipse, you click on Help,
install new software, put in
the URL, click Add, name it
something-- m2eclipse.
This will go ahead and try
to connect to the site.
You click on it.
You click Next.
It's going to calculate
dependencies.
This could take a long time,
depending on what you're
installing.
But you just kind of click
through the menus until this
thing installs.
I'm not going to show you how to
do this, because I already
have Maven integration
on my laptop.
So we're just going to
go ahead and start
importing the project.
So I'm going to click
file, import.
And what you want to select is
existing Maven projects.
So if it doesn't show up right
away-- and it shows up because
I was just working on this--
type in Maven in the filter,
and this will filter down to
every kind of import step that
includes the word Maven.
And again, you want to select
existing Maven projects.
I'm going to click next.
Now we're going to browse
the root directory
of the samples folder.
I put this in my downloads
directory, so let's go ahead,
and let's go to my home
directory-- ooh, there's a lot
of stuff in here.
We're going to go
to downloads.
I'm going to go to
youtube-api.samples--
this is what it unzips into.
I'm going to click
on samples, Java.
We have all of our samples
in all different
languages on here.
Now I'm going to go into
a search sample.
Now that I'm in the root of the
directory, I'm going go
ahead and click Open.
And notice that there's
a pom.xml.
If you've used Maven before,
you should be
familiar with this file.
It defines the dependencies.
But if you don't know what this,
don't worry too much
about it for now.
I'm going to go ahead and click
Finish, and it's going
to go and start importing this
project into my sample.
Now this went pretty quickly
because I've already done this
before, but on your first time
doing this it might take a
little bit longer, because what
Maven does is it looks to
see what the dependencies are.
And it goes ahead and it
downloads into a local cache
on a local machine.
If you already have those
dependencies, it's basically
just copying a file.
If you don't have these, that's
when it has to connect
to the internet and download
the dependencies.
So when I open search.java--
and I have a humongous font--
I've got a bunch of
imports here.
And you see that I didn't
have to do anything--
Maven just automatically
included all of these
dependencies even though these
are not in the .zip file.
So I can go ahead and-- and you
can see that I don't have
any errors--
run this code by going
to Run, Run.
Enter a search term.
I'm surprised that worked, but I
think it's because I already
edited this code earlier.
There's a youtube.properties
where you enter an API key,
and that's why this code
is able to work.
So let me just open up a quick
file so you can see what this
looks like.
This is pom.xml, and let's
open up the raw XML.
And this is an XML file that
defines all the different
dependencies that your project
has as well as where to go to
download these.
So you're saying, oh, you've got
to go to Maven repository.
And you're going to go
ahead and download--
we need Google API services, we
need the YouTube client, we
need Google HTTP client, and it
kind of recursively goes in
and downloads the dependencies
of those projects.
So it's a very, very helpful
tool for running code.
As you could see, I put in
that code really quickly.
Whereas if I weren't using Maven
I'd have to go through a
bunch of steps of configuring
.jar dependencies and just
copying files around until I get
the right mix of things to
make it work.
So that's how you do
this in Eclipse.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Actually,
I have a question
if you don't mind.
IKAI LAN: Absolutely.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: In doing that,
do you actually specify
a resource in Maven repository
doing that, or is it getting
it from a central Maven
repository?
IKAI LAN: There is kind of like
a Maven central where a
lot of very common
packages are.
Now, there are ways to configure
Maven to go to
different repositories.
I don't think we're doing
that in pom.xml.
For running the samples, it's
not important because
everything we've done should
just work out of the box.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Perfect.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
You do need an internet
connection.
So it becomes a little bit
tricky if you work in a
company where you have a proxy,
right, because network
proxies are kind of crazy.
Like, you've got all kinds of
different levels of proxies.
You've got proxy settings in
your browser, proxy settings
at your system level, and a
whole bunch of other places
where you can modify proxy
settings, and this causes lots
of craziness to happen.
So, unfortunately, debugging
network proxy is out of the
scope of this show.
I'm trying to move relatively
quickly, so let's go ahead and
talk about IntelliJ.
So IntelliJ is probably
my favorite IDE.
This is a product that I pay
for for doing random stuff.
Even though we're
going to open--
I could probably try to apply
for an open source license,
but because IntelliJ IDEA Pro
is something that costs for
personal development,
I think, like $200.
But JetBrains, the company
behind IntelliJ, has made a
community version that is
extremely good, and it's free.
So anyone can go ahead and
download this, and I'll show
you what I'm talking about--
IntelliJ IDEA.
And well, they say
it's the best.
I mean, they're arguably
biased, but it's
a pretty good IDE.
We click on download, you'll
see that, oh, there's an
ultimate addition, and this is
the addition that you have to
buy a license for.
But there's a free community
edition, and even though they
say it's lightweight,
it's very powerful.
So let's go back to--
this is still Eclipse.
I get confused.
Let's go back.
I'm all confused now
because I have
different weird font sizes.
So we'll open up IntelliJ.
This is the main screen
you see when you
first open up IntelliJ.
And how do we import the samples
so that we can start
writing code?
Again, even though we're doing
this with YouTube API samples,
you could do this with most of
the samples that we have on
developers.google.com as long
as you're using Maven.
You can do this with BigQuery,
Drive API, and
so on and so forth.
So I'm now going to go ahead
and click Import Project.
I cheated--
I already browsed to this.
But, again, it's downloads,
YouTube API
samples, samples, Java.
And let's do something else.
I'm going to go ahead and let's
import myuploads.sample.
This little m here, this
is the Maven symbol.
Let's go ahead and click OK.
And by default, it might
say create project
from existing sources.
You want to make sure to select
import project from
external model.
We are using Maven, so
we select Maven.
We click next, and now you've
got a whole bunch of different
settings, and you can tweak
these as needed.
I don't think I need to change
these too much, so I'm just
going to go ahead
and click next.
Now it's going to ask
you which Maven
project you want to import.
The Maven project we want to
import-- well, it's the name
of the project you
want to run.
In this case, it's
youtube-cmdline-
myuploads.sample.
So now I'm going
to click Next.
And on your first time you're
running IntelliJ, you're going
to need to specify which
JDK you're using.
So what's kind of
cool is that--
this is just a default
Mac one.
If you don't know where the path
is, just go on Google and
look for how to configure
default JDK for IntelliJ IDEA,
or your favorite search engine,
if it's not Google.
Project name.
I know this seems like
a lot, but this
actually very, very easy.
In most cases, you don't need
to change anything here.
Click next, no frameworks,
finished.
Now we're going to go ahead
and start importing this.
And what you'll see is when I
start opening this up, I'm
opening up the Java file.
I'm surprised it worked
right away.
It shouldn't have worked right
away, because it should have
been like, oh, well, you haven't
defined Jackson or any
of these client libraries.
But because I'm using Maven
and I've already run this
before, it's gone and it's
downloaded all of the
dependencies and all of the
libraries you need to run the
sample code.
So let's see what we
need to do here.
When you're running the myupload
sample, you need make
changes to client_secrets.json.
And this shouldn't
work, because I
recently reset this key.
But I'm going to go ahead
and run this now.
MyUploads, it's going to build
everything, and there.
It's taken me through the OAuth
authorization flow, and
it has bombed out, because I'm
using an invalid client ID,
but don't worry too much
about that right now.
The point is that you don't have
compilation errors, and
things are working right away.
Maven has a bunch of
other features.
So when you right click on your
project, you can scroll
down to Maven, and you can see
some of the different things
you could do.
You can reimport things if
somehow you've messed things
up, if you've deleted
the local .jars.
You can generate sources, and
you can just do a lot of
different things in Maven.
So this is IntelliJ IDEA.
There's just a lot things I like
about this product, which
I like their approach to
a lot of things you
want to do in an IDE.
But then again, it's up to you
which one you want to use.
Both IntelliJ IDEA and Eclipse
are very good options.
I simply prefer to use IntelliJ
for a bunch of
personal reasons.
So that's all I have for now.
So if you have any questions
about how to do any of this
stuff, do find us on Stack
Overflow using
the youtube-api tag.
What I'm going to do now is
I'm going to close down
IntelliJ, and I'm going to
hand this laptop over to
Ibrahim because he
uses Eclipse.
I'm trying to convert
him, and he's
actually pretty open minded.
He said, yeah, I'll
give it a try.
But for this show he's going to
be using Eclipse because he
knows it a little bit better.
So let's go ahead and
do that right now.
I'm going to minimize
my browser, and
let's open up Eclipse.
And I'm going to hand
this over to you.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Cool, thanks.
IKAI LAN: Did you have any
questions about that?
Hopefully, that was
very clear, and
I was able to explain.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I think
that was clear.
So far I was using the command
line of Maven, but using this
way, I think it will make
my life much easier.
IKAI LAN: What I actually do is
I do something different,
where when I'm developing I used
the Maven plug-in, so in
my IDE it imports things
correctly.
But I still also use the
command line heavily.
I use the command line for doing
things, because I prefer
to use the command line for
source control and just doing
these builds.
But again, it's all personal
preference.
Some people like
GUIs and IDEs.
I like a mix of an IDE and
command line based
environment.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Perfect.
IKAI LAN: All right.
Take it away, man.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK, great.
So far, Ikai has made
my life so easier--
upload, import everything,
everything's super set up, all
the dependencies are ready,
so I think I'm good to go.
Now we can just look at our
code a little bit and see
everything we've done.
Maybe we can just see and
go through our code and
understand how it will
augment in YouTube,
how we develop stuff.
So actually, I will start with
search, and I will to the
other three examples of
MyUploads in subscription and
uploading video.
And search is a little bit
different by authorization,
because you'll use just an API
key, but for other stuff,
other examples, we'll be
using the OAuth 2.0.
So we will have a client_secrets
kind of
authorization going through.
Let's look at the code
a little bit.
So in this one, in the search,
everything starts with
authorization, basically.
We'll create or you could build
a class, which is the
class, actually, to create
our YouTube object.
And this is like the
main class you need
to like deal with.
And it will create the YouTube
object that will be
interacting all over the YouTube
development phase.
So we initialize the class,
giving the HTTP request.
We set our application name
as an identifier.
And we build the class, so all
builders like [INAUDIBLE] or
YouTube object is all ready.
For this one, we will need to
have the credentials early,
because we'll be just
using an API key.
So the YouTube model, we'll just
go to the object YouTube
search method to give us
the search object.
And since we want to do like
a search, we'll do
a list of the search.
So we created the YouTube search
list object by using
the YouTube search list.
And anything we want to give
as the parameters, optional
parameters, these are the
resources we want to get back
from all searches out.
So we want the ID and snippet
to be returned back.
IKAI LAN: Now, is this list
object compatible
with Java util list?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: No.
It is not a Java util list.
Maybe there could be
like a small--
people tend to get confused
about it, but it's the YouTube
search list object.
So I'd really like, actually,
rather than importing all the
way to the [INAUDIBLE]
Google YouTube search list, I
would rather just go to the
way it was before the YouTube,
so you will be able to see any
lists in your screen.
You can see, actually, it's
YouTube.search.list.
IKAI LAN: That's a
very good tip.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: If you don't
do it, I think, you may see
the list in both ways,
and you may get
confused really easily.
IKAI LAN: Exactly.
That's a really good tip.
Thank you for that.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: So since we're
doing get authorized
before, we will use
the API key.
For this example, for the sake
of this example, we just get
the API key from a
property object.
And we set it to all
search object.
We create the search
object by the list.
And we want to actually have
a query term, because it's
either from the user--
for this example, we just
get it from the
user, the query term.
We want, actually, for this one,
we just want the videos
to be returned, not the
playlist or channels.
For this one, just videos.
We set the type.
The field is an optional
parameter, if you want just
the few fields to be returned
rather than
everything in that resource.
We want that one, we set
the maximum resource.
And after we set all these
objects, and we make it ready
for execution, all we need
to do is execute.
And this time, we execute it.
And since it's a source list
execution, it will return us
the list of search results.
Not to confuse, this time we
are using the Java list.
IKAI LAN: Now this time
it's a Java list.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
This time is a Java list.
So since we named the other one
as YouTube.search.list, so
it is obvious that this time we
are using the other list.
IKAI LAN: So just to clarify, a
YouTube.search.list, you're
not actually creating an
object that's a list.
You're creating an
API request doc.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: Because the API
request, if you look at the
URI when you go to the
API explorer, it
is slash list, right?
It's very in this kind
of RESTful style.
So again, that is a
request object.
And this is an actual
list of objects.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
The one we created first
was a request object.
And this one is actually
our response.
So any time, the way we'll be
going on all these examples is
we will be creating the
request, modify it if
necessary, and once we do the
execution, after execution we
will get like a response
object.
This object here is like a type
of list search results.
So we will have all the search
results inside our list.
And we can, for this example,
we can just go over the list
and get all the things we want
inside the object, which will
be like search results.
I will move over, and I will
just go to other examples,
actually going through the
OAuth2, which is the suggested
way of using our APIs.
IKAI LAN: So one nice thing
about this while he's setting
up this project I'll talk about
is that I really like
the Python client.
I think it reads
really nicely.
It's very concise.
It works really well.
You do have some advantages
when you're using the Java
client, which is that you have
type safety, which allows the
autocomplete to be
somewhat useful.
Now, this can also be
frustrating in some instances
when you make an API request and
you must pass a specific
instance of a certain
type of object.
But while you're learning the
API, just having autocomplete
to say YouTube dot search dot
what are my methods, oh, is it
the right number of parameters,
it's very, very helpful.
So there's kind of
win and lose.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
I think when I first started
doing my own examples on the
Python, it was fast,
and it was good.
But on the other hand, like when
I'm stuck somewhere, and
I don't know which is the right
object type, that was a
time that I was like, oh,
maybe Java would be much
easier that way.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And definitely use the YouTube
API explorer that's on
developers.google.com to kind of
figure out what to pass in,
because your alternative is
you're writing code and
testing, writing code
and testing.
The YouTube API explorer, it
will deal with the-- it will
manage the authentication
for you.
And you can try different
things until you find a
combination that works.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And in
documents it says which ones
are the required parameters,
which are the optionals.
So definitely go there.
Definitely go whenever you are
stuck in something that you
are not sure what kind of
parameter you want to pass, or
you are getting responses like
bad request, definitely go
there and check it out, which
is the right one.
IKAI LAN: So what are
we looking at now?
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: It
is my uploads.
So we want to try to get like
all the uploads related to our
own channel.
So this one, we will use, as I
explained, the OAuth2 kind of
authorization from
a client secret.
For installed applications, we
use this [INAUDIBLE], using
the authorization code flow,
which actually when you
actually run the client and run
the user, wants to use our
application, he uses own
identity and logins that he
authorizes with his identity.
And once it's passed, we will
save the identity to the
client sequence JSON, not the
password, not the user name,
just the token.
IKAI LAN: Again, not the user
name and not the password.
This is very important.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah, this
is like the approved way.
We don't want to save users'
credentials in this way.
So we try to check it.
And for this example, if the
client sequence file is
nonexistent, we try to
get it from the user.
And once we get it,
we want to--
IKAI LAN: Let's just browse
to it real quick.
If you need to edit this, it's
in source, main resources.
Its client_sequence.json.
I was considering refactoring
this to use a properties file,
just because it's kind of silly
in this instance how
we're loading Jackson
just so we can load
this one tiny JSON.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: That would
be much easier.
IKAI LAN: Not a huge deal,
though, I don't think,
especially since we're
using Maven.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
Maven will be doing all the--
so from our JSON once we sent it
over there, we were able to
just read it as a credentials
store.
And what we will do is we will
pass these credentials, but we
will set the credential to our
Google authorization code
flow, which will do the
flow for ourselves.
And we will have the local
receiver for it.
And here at this line, since we
are using an installed app
and in the API console we set it
as an installed app, using
the credentials, we were able
to use this flow, use the
local receiver we just created
in this line, and
authorize the user.
At this line, once the user puts
his authorization, gives
that authorization with
the right scopes--
it's really important to use
with the right scopes.
You may have problems if you
don't use the right scopes,
which you will also find in
the documentation, which
scopes are needed for what
kind of requests.
Here we have for this one, we
have the Google API slash
OAuth slash YouTube scope,
which is both
read and write scope.
This is like the full
authorization.
There is also the actual three
scopes I will go over today,
the YouTube.readonly, which
will only give read-only
access, and YouTube.upload,
which is
able to upload videos.
So using the previous method
we authorized, now we are
ready to go and do the similar
way as we did before.
We created our YouTube
builder object.
And look at this small
difference here.
We actually pass our
credentials, since we
authorized with that
credential.
And we don't need to set API
keys anymore, since we are
already authorized.
This one is like
we did before.
We will create a channel request
object, channel list
request object.
You want to return the
contact details.
And we want only my videos, my
channel's content, basically.
And we'll set mine to true.
IKAI LAN: And set mine true just
means return my uploads.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
Just my uploads.
Basically, for this one, my
channel and my uploads.
IKAI LAN: And when you look
inside the API explorer, what
this maps to is a field that
says mine, true or false.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
And as we did before,
we will create the
channel request object.
And we execute it.
And this one, again, we will
return the list of Java
utilities kind of channels.
If you go to the channel
resource in the documents, you
will be able to see the
resources like the contact
details, snippet ID.
And inside contact details,
there's a field
called related playlists.
So we want to actually get from
that channel's response,
which is [INAUDIBLE]
I'll be able to get all
my channel back.
So I will go through and get my
uploads inside the channel,
which is a playlist
called uploads.
IKAI LAN: So this is something
that's a little bit confusing
to people, which is, how
do I fetch my uploads?
They're now a playlist.
And they're now specifically
a related
playlist and an upload.
So this is to be aware of.
People are always asking us,
how do I get my uploads?
You make a get playlist
call essentially.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yes.
Some people are confused, and
they want to go to videos and
try to search from there, but
the right way is going to the
channels and get it from that.
So inside the get playlist
there is an
upload field as well.
And with this one, we were able
to get my upload, which
is a playlist.
So now, since we have a list
of playlist items, which
playlist actually has items
of playlist item.
And every item is essentially
like it's a video or another
item in it.
And this is where, actually,
you will be able to get all
the upload video, since we said
only set mine before.
In this one, we'll
go through the--
since now we have the playlist
item list, and not the
playlist itself, we only get
the playlist up to now.
Now we want to go into the
playlist and fetch all the
videos inside it.
So it's a two-step process.
So far, we were able to get
the playlists inside.
And we will get the first
playlist out of there, which
was our upload playlist.
And putting the playlist item,
playlist items, that list is
another request object we
will be using there.
IKAI LAN: So essentially, what
you're saying is we're making
two requests to get
up our uploads.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
First request was
get the channel,
get the channel request.
And we get over channel
the uploads, the
upload playlist ID.
And once we get that playlist,
now we will go to that
playlist and request the items
inside that playlist.
With this one, we
set the fields.
And now we set page tokens,
because there will be subpages
over there if you already
had a token before.
Maybe it will be empty,
or maybe we went
to the first page.
And you only get a second
page in the example.
So we'll go through all the
pages by going with page
tokens done by [INAUDIBLE].
Build the loop for that, and
every time you put a new page
token, we will execute our
request again with the new
page token.
And for the sake of this
example, we will add them to a
normal Java list.
We will keep populating all
the results we will gain
through the different pages.
And once we have all the
requests, we can just print it
out or we can use which one
we are interested in.
And that's all I have
for my uploads part.
I'll do an upload video, which
I was getting questions about
it before, how we upload video,
especially I was like--
maybe it's a good time to talk
about it a little bit.
I was working on
an Android app.
And some people were asking,
oh, you want to make an
Android app and upload
some media.
How are we going
to get samples?
They couldn't find inside
Android samples,
that kind of stuff.
Actually, if you just put this
one into the Android sample,
it will just work, because
they are both
using the Java as well.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
And in Android, you can always
also use the upload intent--
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
Yeah, you can.
IKAI LAN: --which
is really nice.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: You can
just-- totally, yeah.
IKAI LAN: But there are some
people that do want to do this
for whatever reason.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
They want to customize,
and they want to
create their own uploads.
But definitely if you want to
use it, test it right away,
and you want to do
it fast, you can
just create the intent.
IKAI LAN: I will say that if you
try rebuilding the intent,
a lot of engineering work went
into that, like doing the
background uploads.
And there's a lot
that can happen.
When you're uploading using the
intent, it cues up a bunch
of videos, and it shows you an
upload progress in the bar.
There's a lot you
have to build.
It's not a trivial
amount of work.
So before, first examine if you
can already use intents.
Intents are one of the best
features of Android.
And if you're not making
good use of that, well,
what are you doing?
Focus on building your app and
not reinventing every single
[INAUDIBLE].
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
Don't try to reinvent
the wheel.
First try it.
Definitely.
So in this one, we want
to upload a video
style type of video.
So actually this is the file
format we will be putting
while we'll be uploading
the video.
You want it categorized
as a video.
As we did before, we
will do the same.
Authorization levels, this one
the only difference will be we
will be using a different scope
called YouTube.upload.
And we create our file.
It's different from
the other object.
We have to get a file from our
user, or whatever you want to
specify the path.
And once we create the file, in
the video upload request we
will be using both
the file and the
metadata at the same time.
So we will be able to the set
the properties and the
metadata while uploading
the video itself.
We created the new video, which
is the video object we
will be standing
over the wire.
And we want it to be public.
We set this private status.
It's a video status object,
so as we explained before,
everything here will be
like an object, every
field we want to create.
Maybe if you guys are using it
as a dictionary in Python,
here we will be using
as an object for
all of these fields.
It's a video status object, if
you want to set the status.
And we can set status public.
We set it to the metadata we
want to really push it, which
is the video.
It's the video object.
We want to set the
snippet as well.
We create--
just from a calendar, we
just get today's date
or any date we want.
We set snippet as title,
description.
And there was a question of how
we put the text inside.
And you will put the text inside
the snippet as a list,
as a Java list, or a special
list, Java util list.
And [INAUDIBLE]
just for this example.
And we set the snippet with all
the text, the title, the
description.
And you want to push
it to YouTube.
IKAI LAN: Right.
So I noticed that this
is just taking a
standard input stream.
So what we're doing in this
sample is we're specifically
loading from a file.
But if you somehow have a
different input stream, like
say you're loading from a
database and you have that as
an input stream, or an alternate
data source,
anything that's compatible
with the input stream
interface should be able
to-- you just drop
and replace the code.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
Definitely.
As long as there's in input
stream interface that
implemented, you can just
use it right away.
You can plug it in.
So for this one, we want to
create an insert request which
is YouTube videos insert, and
we want to return for this
example snippets status fields
on the way back.
And what we want to put is, we
want to put the input stream
as well as the metadata
as I explained.
So metadata is here.
Input stream you already
got from the user.
We created the file put
this input stream.
And we have a Google's own
metadata HTTP uploader you can
use right away.
It's from the video insert.
You can get the HTTP uploader
from that if you
want to use that one.
So this is a tricky part if you
want to use a resumable
upload, which is the premier,
or if you want to use the
simple normal previous upload,
which tries to do the upload
as one huge chunk.
If you do want to use the
resumable one, it has some
nice features, like you can
also track the progress of
your upload.
You can create, like in this
example, create a progress
listener, which will be like
at every stage of the
progress, you will be getting
notifications.
And you can set display bars,
or you can, in your example,
show by getting this progress
listener, you can track what
percentage of upload you have
sent so far, how many bytes
you have sent for a file.
You can definitely tell
the user how his
upload in going on.
IKAI LAN: On that note, this
is not asynchronous.
If you are writing for
Android, absolutely,
absolutely do this in
the background.
Do not block the UI thread.
Sometimes I still open
Android apps, and I
go, who's doing this?
Don't block UI thread.
Yeah.
And it's true of any-- it's
don't ever block the UI thread
in any mobile application you're
ever writing, be it
Android or iOS.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah.
So like here we implemented
the progress listener.
And now we set our progress
listener to our uploader.
And now we are all good to go.
We will just create our insert
object before, request object
before, we will just
execute it.
And the way it will return,
it will return the media
metadata, the one returned
from the service,
the response object.
From that, we can get anything
we want, we ask for, like
[INAUDIBLE]
the statistics about it.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And the [INAUDIBLE] we would do
if we want to, again, edit
the video data after the fact,
or add it to a playlist or
things of that sort.
Yes.
So hopefully--
did you want to show any more
samples, because I just wanted
to say that we are a little
bit out of time.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: I think that
was like the main one, and it
will get you definitely
started.
If you want more later on, we
can go through or you can
definitely write in
Stack Overflow.
Or you can just go
to-- actually we
already gave the link.
You should definitely go to the
API samples page and check
it out from there.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
And if you have any ideas for
future shows that you want to
see, let us know on any
one of these forms.
Google+ is a very good place to
tell us, hey, you know, I'm
looking to do this.
And if it's something that we
think is going to help a lot
of people, then we'll say,
hey, you know what?
That sounds like a great
idea for a show.
So we'll go ahead and we'll get
cranking on that for you.
So thank you very much for that
introduction and that
very kind of quick code
walk through.
I'm hoping that was helpful
to you guys.
I'm hoping that if you're a
Java developer, it's just
going to make things a little
bit less intimidating.
So yeah, thank you guys
very much for
joining us on the show.
And we'll see you next time.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And
one last note.
We are hiring.
IKAI LAN: Oh, yeah.
That's right.
I always forget this, and they
always get mad at me because I
don't say it.
We are hiring.
It's not just YouTube Developer
Relations that's hiring.
We are hiring pretty much across
every single function
developer relations.
We are hiring in our
multiple offices.
We have the most positions
in Mountain View.
But we also have positions
in New York City, I
think Tokyo, London.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: All
across the world.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
Yeah Just in all of our
different offices.
And Seattle.
I think those are
the main ones.
Anyway, thank you
guys very much.
If you have any questions,
find us on Google+
or on our Plus page.
Or we sometimes look
at the comments
on the YouTube videos.
But we don't check them as
much as we check Plus.
So thank you guys very much.
And tell all your friends
about us.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Definitely.
IKAI LAN: Thanks.
Take it easy.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Have
a good one.